c'est le départ de la huitième semaine
de campagne et pour la première fois des
chefs de partis se rendent à terre-neuve
et labrador
si ça leur a pris du temps
c'est que ce n'est pas ici que la pêche
ou vote rapporte le plus pour le chef du
npd jouer la carte du meneur vient avec
un prix ses adversaires foule son passé
il était hélas progrès et nos portes
jeune et je l'aï retiré à l'époque
thomas mulcair est forcé de s'excuser à
nouveau pour un incident qui remonte à
1996 un candidat libéral lui a reproché
d'avoir alors utiliser le terme nufi à
l'assemblée nationale c'est vraiment
thomas mulcair a aussi dû défendre son
rôle dix ans plus tard dans le litigieux
dossier du mont orford
la presse cite une de ses anciennes
collègues du gouvernement charest qui
affirme que le chef du npd était à
l'origine favorable à la privatisation
de la montagne j'ai refusé de signer le
décret j'ai quitté le conseil des
ministres maintenant de baux sur cette
question de presse à cela s'ajoutent des
déclarations récentes faites aux
coulisses du pouvoir sur la nouvelle loi
antiterroriste qui font aussi réagir ses
adversaires aucune mesure dans ses 51
que vous trouvez qu'il faudra garder en
soi
ok mais adversaire choisissent ou bien
de miser sur la peur des terroristes ou
bien sûr la peur d'un état policier
c'est irresponsable justin trudeau était
d'ailleurs à halifax pour présenter son
plan d'acquisition militaire nous
n'achèterons pas les avions de combat f
même si dans le sud de l'ontario les
pancartes bleues porté exclusivement sur
l'économie stephen harper a sauté sur
l'occasion de revenir sur la lutte
contre le groupe armé ita islamique
nous n'avons pas l'intention
d'abandonner les gens dans la région là
d'abandonner ses capacités pour les
forces à rien si les déclarations
passées des candidats de tous les partis
ont été scrutés à la loupe par leurs
adversaires c'est au tour de thomas
mulcair de goûté à cette médecine
il reste maintenant moins d'un mois
cette longue campagne
il semble bien qu'elle pourrait se
corser
ici madeleine dié morin radio canada
ottawa